good morning heck it's tuesday except
that uh it's not i've been playing a
small trick on you as i'm recording this
it is in fact thursday october 28th i
have secretly pre-made a bunch of
vlogbrothers videos and taken the month
of november off as a sort of mini
sabbatical what led to this minor ruse i
suppose five things first and i hope you
won't take me saying this personally but
work is not the most important thing in
my life it used to be the most important
thing in my life my primary
self-identifier my shorthand for
understanding my value and so on but i
have worked pun intended quite hard over
the last five years to get away from
that sort of thinking the most important
part of my life is interpersonal
relationships with friends and family
and so on and then the second most
important part of my life is
intra-personal my own time for reading
and writing and thinking and exercising
and being now work is very important to
me and i want to do it well but i also
don't want it to be my whole life so i
decided to take a month away from
certain regular obligations like
vlogbrothers and deerhank and john and
some meetings in order to focus on the
other obligations that often don't get
prioritized because they aren't like
economically productive they're just
actually productive like to use a very
basic example a while back i made a
vlogbrothers video about how the most
important time in my day was the time
spent chatting with my kids after
picking them up from school but on the
day i made that video i was actually too
busy to pick them up from school this is
obviously not the proper alignment of
priorities so i'm gonna take a month to
try to figure that out secondly this
whole uh boot situation requires a bit
of rehab thirdly for the last several
years my mental health has been mostly
stable and good which has been great but
then for the last little while it was
not that stable and not that great which
was unfun like you know when you feel
faint your peripheral vision starts to
get clouded it was like that except like
worry was invading from every direction
fortunately that's been getting better
the last couple weeks but i want to
focus on it without neglecting
vlogbrothers like i know i could have
just hit pause on this but i i value the
conversation so much i didn't want to do
that fourth i want to see if taking time
away from regular work obligations gives
me more time and inclination to write
i've talked about this obliquely but
never directly somewhere along the line
though publishing became pretty
unpleasant for me i don't know how much
good it does to get into the details of
this but like publishing was my dream
for most of my life and it was really
fun and fulfilling at the beginning and
then at some point it became mostly
stressful and scary like i would only be
able to think about what if the book is
received terribly and what if people
hate it and what if readers feel like i
cheated them out of the 20 of faith they
placed in me and so on and so to be
honest while i always loved writing that
part of the publishing process became
less something that i enjoyed and more
something that i like
got through but then both the writing
and the publishing process for the
anthropocene reviewed book were really
fun and fulfilling so now i'm not like
in our hurry to write or publish
anything the anthropocene review book's
only been out for a few months it takes
me years to write a book but i'm
actually looking forward to it i'm
enjoying the fun of writing and the
immersion of it and i want to focus on
it and lastly i need to finish these
ridiculously time-consuming circle
drawings one thing i've noticed over the
years is that everything takes longer
than i expected to not least because i
always assume that future me will be
more productive than current me is able
to be so i don't know how much if
anything i actually got done during this
month of secret sabbaticaling but even
if i don't finish the circle drawings or
write anything it will have been a
productive time if it was inter and
intra-personally productive in fact one
of the reasons i'm doing this is to
remind myself hank of what you have
taught me that i need to expand my
definition of productive to include the
things i actually want to produce like
joy and connection and fulfillment next
week there will be another small
surprise and then i will be back to
report on how my time away went hank i
hope you had a good month i'll see you
on friday